[Music]
a lot of people are scared about the eye
and the reason is I think we've seen too
many Terminator movies so we're mixing
many things up so it is true Terminator
is not a scenario we are planning for
but when it comes to artificial
intelligence people get all these things
confuse these robots it's awareness it's
people smarter than us to some degree so
we're effectively afraid of robots that
will move and are stronger and smarter
than we are like terminator so that's
not our aspiration that's not we're not
what I want what I do when I'm thinking
about artificial intelligence when I'm
thinking about artificial intelligence
I'm thinking about it in the same way
that mass manufacturing has brought by
forth created the whole new economy so
mass manufacturing allowed people to get
new jobs that were unthinkable before
and those are jobs actually created the
middle class to me artificial
intelligence is about developing making
computers better partners effectively
and you're already seeing that today
you're already doing it except that it's
not really artificial intelligence today
whenever you want to engage in a project
you go to Google Google uses advanced
machine learning really advanced and you
engage in a very narrow conversation
with Google except that your
conversation is just keywords so a lot
of your time is spent trying to come up
with the actual keyword that you need to
find the information and Google gives
you the information and then you go out
and try to make sense of it on your own
then come back to Google for more and
then go back out and that's the way it
works so imagine that even stead of
being a narrow conversation through
keywords you could actually engage for
more than actual information meaning to
have the computer reason with you about
stuff and you may not know about it's
not so much about the computer being
aware it's about the computer being a
better tool to partner with you and you
would be able to go much further right
the same way that Google allows you to
go much farther already today because
before to the exact same procedure would
have had to go to a library every time
you want to search for information so
what I'm looking for when I do AI is I
want a machine that partners with me to
help me set up or solve real-world
problems thinking about them in ways we
have never thought about before but it's
a partnership now you can take this
partnership in so many different
directions through our additions to your
brain like Elon Musk proposes or through
better search engines or through a
robotic machine that helps you out but
it's not so much they're going to
replace you for that purpose that is not
the real purpose of AI that we our
purpose is for us to reach further the
same way that we were able to reach
further when Ford invented automation or
when Ford brought automation to mass
market people fear that automation might
actually remove jobs and what I want to
stress that is that that's not
artificial intelligence automation is
something we've been doing for ages all
of us you do that your home you do it
with the way you set up your own
schedules you do it for many many things
in some cases it involves computers in
some cases it doesn't now the purpose of
automation is to free time so that we
can reach further so when a company
starts using automation and it raises
certain jobs but doesn't figure out how
to create new ones
then they're mostly just looking at cost
savings they are not looking really at
expanding their own market and that
turns out to be a lack of imagination so
what with the free time and the
expertise that was left free now because
of your automation they should be able
to build and reach further if they don't
it has little to the actual machine
which is somewhat dumb it has more to do
with lack of imagination on the part of
whomever right certainly not the worker
right
[Music]